bonjour à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps grâce aux archives
de la télévision pour mieux comprendre
l'actualité contemporaine vous regardez
l'inattendu et vous êtes les bienvenus
là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils apprennent à
tricoter à votre place la rame et non un
peu moins et si vous ne réussissez pas
c'est qu'il vous manque qu'une seule
chose un tout petit détail à mes côtés
géraldine corner lavaud et qatari
qu'elle dit bonjour à tous les deux
journaliste à la rédaction dina vous
avez sélectionné deux sujets d'actualité
qui trouve un écho particulier lorsqu'on
découvre la manière dont ces thèmes ont
été traités par le passé tahri vous avez
été ému c'est le cas de le dire par le
décollage de space x nous dit on peut
dire que j'ai été ému par ce collège
mais ce qui m'intéresse ce n'est pas
tant la prouesse technique à réaliser
space x c'est plutôt le fait qu'une
entreprise privée 1 je dis bien privés
s'intéressent en tout cas rêve d'
espaces parce que vous savez un elon
musk le patron de space x voudrais vous
en voyez vous géraldine vous nous tous
dans l'espace mais il se trouve que
monsieur musquin prédécesseurs nous
l'avons retrouvée dans nos archives il
s'appelle robert trois axes c'était un
ingénieur et un journaliste français a
essayé son invention 200 volontaires qui
sont prêts à faire un premier voyage
pour un voyage qui devrait durer en tout
15 minutes du décollage à l'atterrissage
car la fusée ensuite avec un parachute
va atterrir ou amerrir dans l'océan
pacifique
en fait on est presque installés
confortablement ici et me voici prêt
pour le premier voyage ou pour être le
premier touriste de l'espace
voilà je sais que vous rêvez à de voyage
est sympa en tout cas dommage
elle marche pas
c'est peut-être pas plus mal on va sur
terre avec la semaine européenne pour
l'emploi des personnes handicapées
c'est l'info vous avez choisi géraldine
pour quelles raisons oui parce que la
france fait encore office de mauvais
élève aujourd'hui 16% c'est un chiffre
impressionnant 16% des personnes
handicapées sont au chômage
c'est quasiment deux fois plus que la
moyenne nationale alors là en pleine
crise sanitaire
on peut craindre que la situation ne
s'empire pourtant en france depuis 1987
une très belle année 1 33 ans une loi
impose aux entreprises de plus de 20
salariés d'embaucher 6 % de travailleurs
handicapés
j'ai voulu montrer cette archive qui
date de 1988 donc un an après cette loi
est le constat n'était pas vraiment
engageant écouter les employeurs
préférés payer des pénalités et aux
chefs d'entreprise finalement qui
rechignent à embaucher des personnes
handicapées qu'est ce que vous auriez
envie de dire essayer c'est l'adopter
non mais qui vous donne au moins un
essai comme comme tout à chacun fait
alors aujourd'hui avec la crise
sanitaire au premier trimestre 2009 1
les recrutements de personnes
handicapées avaient chuté de 30% selon
le collectif handicap
merci beaucoup géraldine alors voilà ça
c'est l actualité de la semaine sinon
que s'est il passé le 18 novembre
ces dernières années c'est le zapping de
l'ina ça s'est passé un 18 novembre
regarder
si les 18 heures heure locale 23h heure
française lorsque florence arthaud dans
le soleil couchant se rapproche de la
ligne d'arrivée entouré d'une myriade de
bateaux accompagnateurs
ce petit bout de femme perchée sur sa
grande araignée géante gagne la route du
rhum la première à remporter une course
transocéanique les hommes politiques
arrivent le luron les avait croqué avec
des mots parfois acide mais ce matin pas
de rancune
les visages sont graves on s'extasie en
choeur devant tant de beauté réunis
finies les polémiques sur les grands
travaux de françois mitterrand jugé un
temps trop dispendieux quand l'actuelle
majorité était dans l'opposition
êtes vous vraiment un médecin dans un
mois le bouchon de millau ne sera plus
qu'un mauvais souvenir mais avant
l'ouverture du fameux viaduc des essais
en pleine charge ont été effectués cet
après midi 28 camions chargés de 960
tonnes de gravats se sont positionnés
successivement entre deux piles du
viaduc
décidément les grands de la grande
époque nous quitte après calder c'est
man ray qui viennent mourir
man ray était devenu le photographe du
groupe surréaliste il inventait la
photographie surréaliste et au delà ils
découvraient de nouvelles techniques et
mieux un nouvel art de la photographie
bonsoir et à demain
la télé peut-elle remplacer les
professeurs pendant le premier
confinement le petit écran a offert une
exposition inédite à l'enseignement et
aux programmes scolaires la maison lui
mis notamment sur les chaînes du service
public
l'émission qui est toujours diffusée
actuellement sur france 4 tarik la télé
qui endosse le rôle du prof
on sait pas nouveau mais à quand remonte
le premier cours télévisés
ça remonte à une soixantaine d'années
exactement 1953 alors ce qui s'est passé
à l'époque c'est que le ministère de
l'éducation c'est détient comment est-ce
qu'on va un peu modernisé notre bonne
vieille école de la république et la
solution c'était la télé bon à l'époque
même pas 1% des ménages est équipé alors
ont regardé cette télé en place la
télévision considéré comme moyen
d'enseignement passe dans le domaine
pratique dans les classes primaires
commence aujourd'hui à fonctionner trois
fois par semaine des cours réguliers par
télévision c'est une innovation
considérable qui vient s'ajouter aux
cours par radio inauguré l'an dernier
cette nouveauté ne supprimera pas bien
entendu le maître ou le professeur dont
le rôle est toujours essentiel mais elle
semble appelé à élargir dans le réel et
dans la vie la portée de son
enseignement on l'a vu à la télé se fait
une place à l'écran lui promet un très
bel avenir dans les années 60 ce sont
quatre heures de programmes acquis sont
diffusés chaque semaine je rappelle
qu'avec eux deux chaînes à l'époque dont
que c'était déjà quand même pas mal pour
les plus faciles pour changer de chaîne
c'est tellement plus facile on avait
moins à zapper je vous le confirme on va
voir quand même une archive matériel de
voir à quoi ça ressemblait quand même
une archive de 1965
petit cours de géométrie vous allez tous
comprendre rien de compliqué niveau cp
ce1 sur le cercle et le disque on
regarde le nom le dit rob raisons toutes
les positions que peut occuper le verger
position de la chaire pour à athènes
c'est bon c'est clair pour tout le monde
dise moi ce qui est sûr car il sait que
ces programmes ont disparu dans les
années 80 mais pour mieux réapparaître
un petit peu plus tard très bien l'année
progressé on avait bien progressé il y
avait beaucoup plus de couleurs il y
avait de la mise en scène et tout ça
c'est grâce à la chaîne du savoir
ancêtre de france 5 qui s'appelle la
cinquième donc je vous le dis c'était
des cours beaucoup plus colorée mise en
scène et surtout on pouvait les regarder
en dehors des heures de classe à la télé
à la maison j'en ai vu une dizaine pour
vous mais mon préféré on va le regarder
tout de suite niveau ce1 cours d'anglais
[Musique]
could find
et ben voila je partage avec vous cette
musique et blain trotte dans la tête
depuis des jours mais bon on rigole on
rigole mais c'est courtrai ludique très
coloré tout ça et bien c'est fini à
partir de 2001 parce que la cinquième
déjà 35 qui on préfère diffuser alors
des dessins animés plus tôt de la course
qui est incroyable c'est qu'il a fallu
une crise sanitaire beh pour qu'on pense
à ressortir ses cours du placard et oui
il a fallu une crise sanitaire
mais ce n'est pas celle à laquelle vous
pensez se décale qu'ovide c'est la
grippe aviaire il ya presque 15 ans en
2006 alors le ministère de l'éducation
avait mis le paquet en il avait
enregistré l'équivalent de trois mois de
cours du cp à la terminale je vous
propose de regarder les coulisses de ces
enregistrements
alors maintenant à ton avis où placer le
vendredi sur la crise est ce que ça sera
plutôt ici ou bien ici dans le fond de
la régie un inspecteur de l'éducation
nationale qui ne supporte pas la moindre
approximation
il est prévu une centaine de jours ci à
un risque de pandémie généralisée
donc ça fait trois mois que nous nous ne
vont de préparer trois mois d'émission
ces enregistrements coûte un million
d'euros voilà un million d'euros à la
poubelle mais c'est court c'était un
principe de précaution des jeunes qui
avait déjà de quoi faire si jamais on
avait dû fermer les écoles ils ont
failli servir en 2009 pour une autre
pandémie celle de la grippe h1n1 qui n'a
pas non plus provoquer la fin la
fermeture des écoles mais bon ça aura
fait un petit une petite répétition pour
ce qu'on a traversé au mois de mars
dernier
et puis on sait grâce à vous ces cours
sont disponibles sur linas exactement la
maison l'une ni nos partenaires toute
plaisanterie mise à part aller cour de
la maison lui ni lui ont attiré jusqu'à
plus d'un million de téléspectateurs
pendant le confinement merci beaucoup
tariq
[Musique]
ce soir à minuit beaujolais nouveau va
enfin pouvoir être commercialisé un
lancement habituellement synonyme de
fête de convivialité bonjour périco
légasse journaliste critique
gastronomique critique vinicole la fête
a quand même un petit goût amer
finalement on va voir si le beaujolais
nouveau peut se vendre sans le décorum
et autour la fête quoi alors d'abord il
tombe très bien puisqu'on est dans une
période un petit peu de morosité avec ce
confinement sanitaires et le rôle du vin
c'est d'apporter du bonheur et de la
joie dans les familles on n'est pas
obligé d'être 450 pour boire un bon coup
on a même dit il ya des gens alors je
dis moi je dis je lance un appel
national profité de ce lancement du
beaujolais nouveau qui est accessible
chez les cavistes chez les vignerons il
ya tout un pas de mise en place pour
pouvoir y accéder et fait la fête
donc ce jeudi soir en célébrant le vin
de france à fin mai chez vous oui oui
avec mois de mai les français le savent
bien là depuis six mois on est dans la
prudence la plus totale
ce soir on va se lâcher un petit peu et
on va avoir quelques bonne gorgée de
beaujolais nouveau 2020 qui est
excellent et on va voir à la santé
d'abord de ceux qui se battent pour eux
contre cette maladie
et puis espérer y aura des jours
meilleurs très bientôt l'année prochaine
c'est pas le droit pour le bois encore
augusto péricaud on va retracer
l'histoire de ce vin primeur avec
géraldine géraldine vous vouliez
commencer par nous mettre dans
l'ambiance sur wii va dans l'ambiance du
beaujolais nouveau un basque bas si on
va le faire cette année à la maison ça
n'empêche pas de le fêter
d'habitude on aime bien le faire dans
les bars dans les cafés de retrouver les
copains pour le fêter la bouteille du
beaujolais nouveau cette année sera but
à la maison
confiné alors heureusement les archives
sont là pour nous mettre un peu de baume
au coeur je vous laisse regarder où
j'allais nouveau est arrivé il ya trois
syriens par la voix la wii
le beaujolais nouveau est arrivé
voulait y en a pleins d'esprit soyeuse
et fruité c'est la juda de notre ère
[Musique]
voilà un régime sans pareil à vous avez
la chanson dans la tête je l'espère
normalement voilà le beaujolais nouveau
c'est ça c'est une fête c'est tous les
copains autour du comptoir c'est surtout
le résultat péricaud d'une immense
opération marketing dans unique dans le
monde du vin dès 1951 les vignerons du
beaujolais obtiennent l'autorisation de
vendre leurs vins en primeur avant
décembre
la présentation du beaujolais nouveau
est alors fixé au 15 novembre et
opération marketing fonctionne tellement
bien qu'elle ait fixé par décret je dis
bien un décret 1 à tous les troisièmes
jeudis du mois de novembre à partir de
1985 le beaujolais nouveau tout ce
rituel de fait de chansons
en fait on a l'impression que c'est
ancestrale mais ça remonte aux années 80
c'est un énorme coup marketing n'est ce
pas là une image c'est les trente
glorieuses en toute la ferveur
alors je suis désolé géraldine ce qui
est totalement faux c'est devenu un
phénomène marketing quand les voyous la
grande distribution en ont fait un
produit industriel mais en 1951
on boit le vin nouveau depuis la nuit
des temps je vais vous dire c'était le
le seul vin c'est même le seul vin que
l'être humain a bu jusqu'à pasteur
puisque c'était le vin frais qui était
buvable parce qu'ils étaient frais ils
étaient fruité et puis ensuite avec le
temps des clés les beaux jours arrivent
et le vin piqué puisqu'on ne sait pas
conserver et on buvait un rack été
abîmée bon l'airé romanité de la résine
le vin nouveau c'est le vrai vin c'est
le seul vrai vin pour les amateurs de
vin on le boit dès qu'il naît au 20
novembre à la fin des vendanges
on attend noël et entre temps jusqu'à
pâques et c'est un vin de ferveur et de
partage dans les années 50 kg 1 c'est
une opération qui peut du tout marketing
c'est une fête vigneronne ce sont des
journalistes qui sont allés pendant la
guerre à lyon se réfugier puisque paris
était occupé
ils ont découvert ce rituel après la
libération il le ramène à paris
ça s'est pendu tout doucement dans les
bistrots de biens jours c'est devenu une
grosse opération marketing et a eu des
gros négociant le succès à l'étranger
le japon les états unis des cargos
entiers qui partait avec des milliers
d'hectolitres de beaujolais et c'est
devenu une foire d'empoigné
parce que j'allais vers la finance s'en
est emparé mais ça reste une fête
vigneronne partagé par les français
populaire et
vous dire pendant 30 ou 40 ans avant
qu'il ne devienne ce qu'il est devenu il
ya encore d'excellents beaujolais
nouveau 1
eh bien c'était vraiment la fête du
partage et de la convivialité
c'était pas du tout vous parliez de
l'étranger et c'est vrai que ces images
que l'on vient découvrir sur la fête du
beaujolais en france
ce soit exportée avec le vin oui vous
l'avez dit le japon particulièrement
donc dans les années 80 il ça devient un
marronnier au moment du projet les
nouveaux il ya forcément un sujet jt sur
ce beaujolais nouveau qui arrive au
japon
je vous laisse regarder cet extrait
c'était un sujet qui date de 1987
depuis quatre cinq ans le beaujolais
primeur fait recette sur le marché
japonais
durant la deuxième quinzaine de novembre
chaque année à pareille période
l'aéroport international de tokyo
connaît à son tour la grande messe du à
nouveau la voc du beaujolais primeur au
japon c'est aussi une contribution
médiatique hors du commun une bonne
dizaine de télévisions à tokyo arrose
tout au long de ce mois de novembre
l'arrivée du primeur dans les multiples
émissions d'information pourquoi les
japonais aiment beaucoup sur 20
c'est parce que très léger
facile à bohal est aussi la couleur est
rayé
les fans il boucle donc on le voit dans
cette archive au japon mais le
beaujolais s'exporter aussi aux états
unis en angleterre en écosse exacte sans
vraiment partout à travers ses toutes
les frontières
comment expliquer un tel raz-de-marée de
ce vin primeur à l'étranger c'est un
vrai bonheur c'est un mal facile à boire
qui donner du plaisir c'est un rituel
français on buvait à la gloire de la
france
ça m'inspire une inflexion aujourd'hui
on exporte des centaines de millions de
masques pour ce projet dit du comice 19
et bien à l'époque la france exportait
son bonheur et son plaisir à travers le
beaujolais travers le monde c'est quand
même un symbole plus encourageants que
celui d'aujourd'hui c'est toujours du
commerce extérieur sauf qu'aujourd'hui
on l'export de la médecine aujourd'hui
qui vient de chine un des basques
chinois eh bien l'époque c'était la
france qui est inondé le monde non pas
avec un virus mais avec un mec qui est
donné du bonheur et du plaisir
perry que dans les années 80 toujours le
la production de beaujolais représente
40 % du vignoble de la région
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
producteurs de la région du beaujolais
était content de ce qu'il faisait
où est-ce qu'ils avaient flairé le bon
filon et ça ce monde il ya toujours une
poule aux oeufs d'or et on a multiplié
la poutze aux oeufs d'or par 2 ou par 3
on a augmenté les volumes on a augmenté
les rendements on a un petit peu abîmé
l'image de ce bac était je rappelle
l'invs un paysan est populaire et je
vous dis la grande distribution sont en
étant paru certains négociants sont
emparés pour faire du chiffre d'affaires
du business et on a terni l'image
hélas en plus sont abîmés 20 du coût
argent ça parce que quand on exploite
officiellement une un produit agricole
ont la bim mais ça veut pas dire pour
autant qu'il reste pas beaucoup de bon
beaujolais nouveau et je souhaite que
cette année le 2020 qui est un très bon
millésime
rv réconciliera le vin nouveau le
beaujolais nouveau avec avec le plaisir
de boire ensemble à la maison parce
qu'il est pas que dans des bistrots en
famille à cinq ou six je crois voilà une
bouteille de beaujolais nouveau le 19
novembre 2020
c'est peut-être une lueur d'espoir pour
passer de mes yeux des jours meilleurs
l'année prochaine vous parlais justement
de poule aux oeufs d'or dans les années
80 j'aimerais d'ailleurs vous faire
écouter ce négociant en vin on né en
1984 et déjà il flaire que cette poule
aux odeurs au zoo aux oeufs d'or
évidemment je vais y venir justement que
cette poule aux oeufs d'or a ses limites
écouter le temps 84
il ya des excès comme surtout à quel
endroit n'y at-il pas d'excès quand les
choses sont parfois un peu trop facile
mais il y a en en eux mêmes un espèce de
gyroscope qui ramène à la réalité en
disant attention les gars faut pas faire
les cons
jusqu'à présent on a gagné il faut pas
trop tirer sur la ficelle alors faut pas
trop tirer sur la ficelle faut pas faire
là qu'on les comptes pourtant on l'a dit
il ya ces histoires de levure ou banane
goût framboise même des soupçons
d'ajouter de la betterave pour sucrer
encore plus serein on accuse les
vignerons de faire pisser lavigne qu'est
ce que ça veut dire à quel moment ça
arrive tous ces stands à revoir je vous
le verset parce que celui-ci est le
grand qui m'a appris à déguster des
grandes bouteilles et c'est avec lui que
j'ai vu les meilleurs beaujolais du
monde ça veut dire que technologiquement
on peut tripoter augmenter les jeux
dédiés augmenter les volumes s'étaient
des millésimes il est pas le
réchauffement climatique donc on faisait
la chaptalisation ont rajouté du sucre
dans le moût fermentation pour augmenter
le degré alcoolique 1 ont passé de 8 à 9
degrés à 11 12 13 degrés alors que la
loi autorise deux degrés d'augmentation
par la chaptalisation aujourd'hui plus
besoin
il ya tellement soleil qu'au contraire
les raisins sont très mûrs et puis on
aime et et des arômes artificiels
l'arôme de madame ses larmes 71 b vous
avez toujours des malotrus des chimistes
qui pour des raisons de fric
après nos vignerons à modifier leurs
produits pour le rendre plus présents
sur le marché
c'était inutile le beaujolais spezza
lui-même donc conjonction d'intérêts
financiers de mercantilisme technique et
puis de besoin de faire des profits dont
rien n'avait pas et on a transformé un
produit qui était populaire et et
spontanée en une grande opération six
ans ils ont tué la poule aux oeufs d'or
alors ils ont tué la poule aux oeufs
d'or tant mieux parce que c'était elle
était devenue une méchante poule une
mauvaise poule
aujourd'hui le beaujolais nouveau qui
sort des caves du beaujolais c'est du
bon beaujolais cette période est
terminée
peut-être que le confinement va encore
plus j'allais dire clarifier les choses
parce qu'on en a besoin de qualité de
vérité et je peux vous dire que voir des
clés vignerons du beaujolais
je vais pas dire je les connais tous les
gens prenaient un grand nombre qui se
lancent dans cette opération font du
vrai vin font du vin juste font du vin
pur font du vin propres et que le
beaujolais nouveau
comme quand j'ai connu quand j'étais
gamin dans les années 70 c'était du jus
de fruit un pur bonheur
fruité gouleyant et bien je mets au défi
aujourd'hui qui compte de me trouver un
beaujolais nouveau qui soit pas à la
hauteur des ambitions qu'on peut avoir
quand on veut passer un bon moment donc
plus de qualité moindre quantité et ça
se voit dans les chiffres parce que les
chiffres sont impressionnants regardez
regardez cette courbe 807 mille
hectolitres de beaujolais nouveau
produit en 1988 c'est l'année record on
est en plein boom du beaujolais nouveau
du marketing des grandes surfaces dans
les années 2000 simple aux 380 2541
hectolitres de beaujolais nouveau
produit et l'année dernière on était à
161 mille hectolitres produits
du coup c'est quoi la conclut jean c'est
de dire on produit moins mais en
produits meurent moins mais mieux
on était allé beaucoup trop beaucoup
trop vite beaucoup trop fort c'est vrai
en tout on peut l'appliquer à tous les
concepts commerciaux
là on va revenir sur une des bases et
j'allais dire les productions qui sont
dures et elles plus conforme à la
réalité de la vigne ça va à mon avis ça
va augmenter ça va peut-être doublé de
ce que c'est aujourd'hui le beaujolais
volo nouveau c'est un vin qui est dans
une période très très très déterminée
pendant un court laps de temps
tous les vignerons ne le font pas ce
qu'ils le font le font bien et je pense
que ça ne peut redevenir un rituel dans
toute la france à la maison dans les
bistrots dans les rues alors avoir une
modération ça tombe très bien il faut le
faire avec modération
et puis on le partage dans le calme et
la sérénité ça reste un bon moment moi
je suis pas inquiet sur le tour du
beaujolais nouveau et je crois que la
période où on était parti dans une
espèce de folie mercantile et
industriels cette période déterminée
c'est pas notre époque qui veut ça et on
va retrouver un vrai vin qui donne du
plaisir et du bonheur d'entendre ce que
le beaujolais n'avait pas mieux à faire
dans les années 50-60 que que de se
lancer dans ce beaujolais nouveau est
plutôt se concentrer sur sur des vins un
petit peu traditionnelle il ya des vins
fabuleux quand même dans le beaujolais
vous avez totalement raison d'un panel
le beaujolais stars y tuer l'ancien je
vous dis que c'était le seul vin qu'ils
avaient sur terre de buvards et de
consommables pendant des milliers
d'années
depuis quatre ans pasteur on ne boit que
du vin nouveau dans le beaujolais
c'était la meilleure arme beaujolais il
ya dix crus dans le fameux juliénas
morgon le saint-amour je vais pas tous
les citer le chiroubles le brouilly qui
sont des crues c'est le même cépage si
le gars mais où
beaujolais tout court et le beaujolais
villages c'est un aussi des vins qui
sont des vins de soif et de plaisir et
vous avez des vins de garde parce qu'il
ya aussi des grands crus comme à
bordeaux
et comme à bourgogne vous avez des
grands flux dans le beaujolais ils n'ont
pas ce statut officiel mais vous avez
des magnifiques qui tienne je suis né en
1959 est un jour georges duboeuf qu'on a
pas citées ici me fais goûter avant l
aveugle et je lui dis qu'est-ce que si
on dirait un grand bourgogne
eh bien non c'est en 1950 que vous savez
ce que c'était c'était un beaujolais
nouveau 1959 pour prouver que c'est un
vrai vin qui se garde très longtemps je
veux dire que le nouveau sauvegarde du
beaujolais nouveau contre contrairement
à ce que son nom indique puisque c'est
un vin pur et quand il est propre et
pure c'est havas qui fait des miracles
et qu'il peut se garder 61 ans comme la
ffo voulez goûter avec georges besse on
le voit cette image des années 80 de ce
vin au goût de banane est colle encore à
l'étiquette du beaujolais nouveau
aujourd'hui l'inter beaujolais
d'ailleurs communique plus sur tout ce
qui est mort gauche tous que juliénas
voilà c'est une communication qui change
complètement en oubliant les est de
mettre de côté le beaujolais nouveau
je veux dire c'est irréversible il ya
des villes de france qui portent des
noms je dire comme vichy où il faut
faire ce qu'on veut c'est irréversible
il y aura toujours un anathème sur le
beau c'est une mode même de dire le
beaujolais nouveau c'est de la merde bon
et des gens qu'ils n'ont jamais goûté
qui se fait un malin plaisir à le
dénigrer parce que c'est une tendance
très parisienne très bobo parce que dans
le reste de la france
tant mieux ça permettra justement de
faire attention et de ne pas sombrer
dans les excès que l'on a connues et il
y aura plus en plus de bombes aux gelées
il faudra se battre pour convaincre on
n'a pas aimé non mais il ya des gens qui
n'aiment pas le cas mais qui n'aime pas
le goût du lait mais ça je respecte et
qui croient que c'est pas mon nom parce
que c'est pas leur goût mais cette cette
mauvaise image va au contraire les a
obligés à faire attention va augmenter
la qualité et ceux qui le boiron le
boire en ont conscience ce qui le
produiront le produire au avec rigueur
et je crois qu'au contraire c'est la
garantie pour que le beaujolais retrouve
son identité et les instants de bonheur
avec lequel on a pu le portage et
autrefois parce que c'est un vrai vin
c'est un vin simple c'est du jus de
raisin fermenté et il n'ya pas meilleure
définition pour donner pour donner
l'image d'un grand vin que celui du
beaujolais nouveau quand il est bien
fait hélico vous qui a arpenté les
routes de france
les vignes qu'est ce que l'on dit dans
le beaujolais
du beaujolais nouveau ils ont beaucoup
souffert il ya des réunions qu'ils
renonçaient parce qu'il n'arrivait pas à
le vendre c'est une fierté ou c'est une
fierté
c'est l'honneur et c'est l'image c'est
la carte d'identité du beaujolais
nouveau et je suis très touchée par
l'abnégation fait certains vignerons
alors qu'à un moment donné
arrivé avec son beaujolais nouveau à
paris il y avait des anathèmes qui était
terrible même y avait débat auront
disait ici on sonore ou des cafés de ne
pas voir cette finale c'est piquette
beaujolais nouveau est bien l'aveu
négation de ces vignerons qui se sont
battus pour défendre cette image du
beaujolais nouveau qui je le rappelle
est un vrai vin me fait penser
aujourd'hui à jeu avant qu'on se bat
toujours contre quelque chose eh bien on
inversera cette image et les français
comprendront un jour que il y aura
toujours des mauvais beaujolais nouveau
parce qu'il y aura toujours de mauvais
vin partout autant il y en a moins qu'en
bourgogne et à bordeaux dans le cas du
rhône et modem au projet pour des
raisons de surface et cette quantité
mais cette image permet justement de se
ressaisir et de faire en sorte que l'on
retrouve de la rigueur et de la raison
pour un vin qui mérite le respect des
français et je vous dis quand on prend
vraiment le beaujolais nouveau est bon
c'est un grand moment de plaisir un
grand moment de bonheur et merci à vous
un périco légasse de nous avoir fait
partager votre passion pour pour le vin
et les bonnes choses de la vie et on
vous souhaite un bon beaujolais nouveau
confiné merci également à vous géraldine
avant de se quitter comme chaque semaine
notre pépite dégoter dans les archives
de l'ina cette semaine on vous montre
comment les jeunes 2970 imaginé l'an
2000 elle est pour eux le progrès le
plus important a souhaité pour l'an 2000
les voitures seront ce que tout
électrique je pense qu'elle construire
sera vaincue que l'on croyait jusqu'à
100 ans puisque les maladies sont
presque toutes vaincu donc mourad
vieillesse
moi je pense que c'est l'abolition de
l'abolition de la guerre de notion de
guerre de la réduction du temps de
travail à 30 heures des villes
meilleures ou une vie sera plus agréable
les communications beaucoup plus rapide
ce sera peut-être difficile d'être
heureux que la vie
trépidante et oppressante qu'on aura ce
moment là tu te plains 3000 saurait y
avoir beaucoup de charge la voile à
l'inattendu c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
on se retrouve mercredi prochain 21h
canal 27 et toute la semaine sur les
réseaux sociaux de france info et de
lina bien sûr un grand merci à hélène de
dons et magali vers main qui nous on
était bien préparé cette émission bonne
soirée